Добрий день! Я - вчителька хімії
Світлана Новікова.
Ми з вами сьогодні продовжуємо вивчати
основні класи неорганічних сполук.
На попередньому уроці ми
з вами розібрали основи
і розчинні, і нерозчинні у воді.
А сьогодні ми будемо розглядати основні
оксиди: їх добування та властивості.
Перед тим, як почати вивчати
хімічні властивості
та добування основних оксидів,
давайте пригадаємо, що таке Оксид.
Ми вже з вами про це говорили,
але я нагадаю.
Оксид - це складна речовина,
яка складається з двох елементів,
одним із яких є Оксиген.
Оксиди умовно можна поділити
на солетворні і несолетворні.
Несолетворних оксидів небагато:
їх всього чотири, їх треба запам’ятати.
Це - Нітроген(I) оксид,
Нітроген(II) оксид,
Карбон(II) оксид і Силіцій(II) оксид.
Солетворні оксиди, у свою чергу,
поділяються на основні,
амфотерні та кислотні.
Наприклад, основні оксиди -
це оксиди металічних елементів:
Кальцій оксид, Купрум(II) оксид.
Кислотні оксиди: Фосфор(V) оксид
і Сульфур(VI) оксид.
Амфотерні оксиди: цинк оксид
і алюміній оксид.
Амфотерні сполуки ми будемо
вивчати на наступному уроці.
Це - складна тема і ми
присвятимо їй цілий урок.
Отже, сьогодні ми з вами будемо
говорити про основні оксиди.
Основні оксиди - це оксиди
металічних елементів.
Фізичні властивості.
Основні оксиди - тверді речовини.
До складу основних оксидів входять
металічний елемент та Оксиген.
За звичайних умов це - тверді речовини.
Зараз ви на малюнку
бачите Купрум(II) оксид
і негашене вапно - Кальцій оксид.
Купрум(II) оксид у нас є.
Ми сьогодні будемо
з ним проводити досліди.
Ось такий порошок чорного кольору.
А зараз давайте розберемо такі важливі
поняття, як основа і основний оксид.
Розберемо, який зв'язок
між цими поняттями,
що таке «основа» і «основний оксид».
Основа і їй відповідає основний оксид.
У чому відповідність?
Відповідність, зверніть увагу,
у валентності.
Натрій завжди одновалентний
(Натрій гідроксид).
Йому відповідає Натрій оксид і навпаки:
Натрію оксиду відповідає
Натрій гідроксид.
Далі Калій гідроксид - йому
відповідає Калій оксид.
Калій завжди одновалентний.
Тому так і говоримо: «Калій
гідроксид - Калій оксид».
Барій завжди двовалентний.
Барій гідроксид (основа) - барій оксид.
Валентність не вказуємо,
тому що ці елементи,
які входять до складу і основ, і оксидів,
мають сталу валентність.
Купруму(II) гідроксид
відповідає Купрум(II) оксид.
Купрум може виявляти
сполуках валентність II і I,
тому це обов’язково
треба зазначати у назві.
Купрум, до прикладу,
може бути і одновалентним:
Купрум(I) гідроксид - Купрум(I) оксид.
Ферум(II) Гідроксид - Ферум(II) оксид.
Отже, кожному гідроксиду
відповідає певний оксид.
Відповідність - у валентності:
яка валентність металічного
елемента в основі,
така сама валентність  і в оксиді.
Добування. Як можна добути оксиди?
Оксиди можна добути окисненням
металічних елементів Киснем.
Тому що оксид складається з двох
елементів, одним із яких є Оксиген.
Тому можна добути окисненням.
Зверніть увагу, я навела
приклад окиснення Літію.
Літій - це елемент першої групи
головної підгрупи,
це - лужний елемент, ми говорили
про це на минулому уроці.
Лужні елементи дуже активні,
і оксид за звичайних умов
може утворювати лише літій,
а Натрій і Калій утворюють
пероксид і надпероксид.
Тому я навела приклад
взаємодії Літію з Киснем.
Кальцій - лужноземельний елемент.
Окиснюється з утворенням Кальцій оксиду.
Купрум.
Якщо реакція окиснення Літію
і Кальцію відбувається
за звичайних умов, то реакція
окиснення Купрума (міді)
відбувається за нагрівання.
При цьому утворюється Купрум(II) оксид -
порошок чорного кольору,
до якого ми сьогодні ще повернемося.
Можна добути оксиди розкладанням
нерозчинних основ -
нерозчинних гідроксидів.
Купрум(II)  гідроксид за нагрівання
розкладається на відповідний оксид
(ми про відповідність сьогодні
вже говорили) і воду.
Зверніть увагу, я зазначила, що мідь
не змінює валентність II,
і в оксиді, відповідно,
також валентність II.
Окиснення складних речовин
(ми це вивчали з вами в 7 класі).
Якщо окиснюється складна речовина,
то утворюється оксид кожного елементу,
який входить до складу цієї речовини.
Наприклад, якщо взяти Метан:
внаслідок окиснення утворюється
вуглекислий газ і вода.
Якщо взяти, наприклад,
Сульфід цинку - складна речовина,
яка під час окиснення утворює два оксиди:
оксид цинку і сірчистий газ -
Сульфур(IV) оксид.
Хімічні властивості.
1. З чим реагують основні оксиди?
Якщо ми говоримо про оксиди,
яким відповідає луг,
тобто розчинна у воді основа,
то такі оксиди реагують із водою
з утворенням лугу.
Наприклад, Натрій оксид
реагує активно з водою
з утворенням Натрій Гідроксиду.
Натрій завжди одновалентний.
Кальцій оксид - це негашене вапно.
Воно реагує з водою з утворенням
гашеного вапна - Кальцій гідроксиду.
А от, наприклад, якщо ми
візьмемо Купрум(II) оксид
(ми з ним сьогодні будемо працювати),
то він з водою не буде реагувати.
Чому цей оксид не реагує, на відміну
від попередніх прикладів?
Тому що відповідний гідроксид -
це нерозчинна у воді основа.
Тож реакція не відбудеться.
Отже, тут можна зробити такий підсумок,
щоб зрозуміти і запам'ятати:
якщо оксиду відповідає луг,
то реакція з водою відбувається.
Якщо оксиду відповідає нерозчинна
у воді основа - нерозчинний гідроксид,
то реакція з водою не відбувається.
2. Основні оксиди реагують із кислотами.
Наприклад, Купрум(II) оксид з кислотою
дає Купрум(II) Сульфат і воду.
Давайте зупинимося трошки на цій реакції.
CuО - це складна речовина:
складається із Купрума і Оксигену.
Кислота складається із Гідрогену
і кислотного залишку.
Речовини обмінюються своїми складовими.
Тобто Купрум стає на місце Гідрогену,
а Гідроген - на місце Купруму.
Утворюється Купрум(II) Сульфат.
Зверніть увагу: в реакціях обміну
валентність не змінюється.
Гідроген стає на місце Купрума
з утворенням води.
Реакція обміну.
Давайте проведемо цю
реакцію і подивимося,
за яких умов CuО буде реагувати
з сульфатною кислотою.
Під час проведення досліду будемо
дотримуватися правил безпеки.
Треба одягнути гумові рукавички.
Зараз спробуємо провести реакцію
між Купрум(II) оксидом
і сульфатною кислотою.
Ми з вами сьогодні вже говорили,
що Купрум(II) оксид - це
порошок чорного кольору.
Беремо невелику кількість порошку.
Цього буде достатньо.
До Купрум(II) оксиду треба додати
(якщо ми саме про цю реакцію говоримо)
сульфатну кислоту - Н2SО4.
Додавати з цієї баночки незручно,
тому додаватиму з хімічного стакану.
Тепер додаємо цю речовину до СuО.
Якщо просто змішати ці речовини, то ми
бачимо, що реакція не відбувається.
Для того, щоб відбулася реакція
Купрум(II) оксиду і сульфатної кислоти,
суміш потрібно нагріти.
При нагріванні обов’язково
дотримуємося правил безпеки.
Закріпляємо пробірку в пробіркотримачі.
Як нагріваємо?
Нагріваємо приблизно під кутом
45 градусів до поверхні столу.
Прогріваємо спочатку всю пробірку,
щоб не було перепаду температур.
Після цього нагріваємо суміш
речовин, які мають реагувати.
Отже, після нагрівання речовини
реагують між собою
з утворенням Купрум(II) сульфату.
Ми бачимо зміну забарвлення.
Це ознака того, що відбулася
хімічна реакція.
Ми з вами сьогодні вже говорили
про добування оксидів.
Давайте одразу зробимо такий
дослід: як можна добути оксид,
а саме СuО із нерозчинної основи.
Що для цього треба?
Треба спочатку добути нерозчинну основу.
Для цього треба взяти розчинну сіль -
у нас є Купрум(II) сульфат
і луг - Натрій гідроксид.
Зручніше додавати
із хімічного стаканчика.
Напевно, можна було використати сіль,
яку ми отримали в попередньому досліді...
От, у нас утворився такий блакитний
Сu(ОН)2 - нерозчинний гідроксид.
Його потрібно нагріти для того,
щоб відбулася хімічна реакція.
Я вже говорила про правила
безпеки під час нагрівання.
Дотримуємося цих правил.
Закріплюємо пробірку в пробіркотримачі,
обережно нагріваємо.
Нерозчинні у воді гідроксиди
розкладаються за нагрівання.
Якщо ми говоримо про Сu(ОН)2 -
нерозчинну у воді основу,
за нагрівання цей гідроксид розкладається
на відповідний оксид - Купрум(II) оксид.
Він чорного кольору.
Вже видно, як утворюється СuО і вода.
Отже, ми з вами одразу
зараз провели реакції,
які доводять хімічні властивості основних
оксидів і показують їх добування.
3. Основні оксиди реагують
із кислотними оксидами.
Наприклад, Кальцій оксид (негашене вапно)
вступає в реакцію з Карбон(IV) оксидом.
При цьому утворюється Карбонат кальцію.
Давайте зупинимося на цій реакції.
Кислотний оксид ми з вами вже розглядали.
Це - оксид, якому відповідає кислота.
Відповідність також у валентності:
Карбон і в оксиді чотиривалентний,
і в карбонатній кислоті.
Тому оксид СО2 (вуглекислий газ)
поводить себе так само,
як карбонатна кислота,
тобто він дає Карбонат.
Тому утворюється Карбонат.
Кальцій - двовалентний,
кислотний залишок від карбонатної
кислоти також двовалентний.
Тому формула солі -
Кальцій Карбонат (СаСО3)
Аналогічна реакція: Кальцій оксид
і Фосфор(V) оксид.
Фосфор(V) оксиду відповідає триосновна
кислота - ортофосфатна (Н3РО4).
Тому оцей оксид в хімічних реакціях
поводить себе так само,
як ортофосфатна кислота,
тобто він утворює ортофосфати.
Кальцій двовалентний завжди,
кислотний залишок від триосновної
кислоти також тривалентний.
Тому формула ортофосфату - Са3(РО4)2.
Отже, давайте підсумуємо.
Ми сьогодні з вами розібрали,
з чого складаються основні оксиди.
Основні оксиди складаються
з металічного елементу і Оксигену.
Їх можна добувати або окисненням металу,
або шляхом окиснення складних сполук,
або розкладанням нерозчинних основ.
Фізичні властивості: всі основні
оксиди - це тверді речовини.
Також ми з вами розібрали
хімічні властивості.
З чим реагують основні оксиди?
Основні оксиди реагують з водою,
але з водою реагують лише ті
оксиди, яким відповідає луг.
Тобто розчинна у воді основа.
Основні оксиди також реагують
із кислотами та кислотними оксидами.
Із кислотами та кислотними оксидами
основні оксиди утворюють сіль.
Тепер давайте спробуємо
розв’язати задачу.
Для досліду було взято еквімолярну суміш
Купрум (ІІ) оксиду і Ферум(ІІ) оксиду.
Про еквімолярну суміш ми
з вами зараз поговоримо.
Обчисліть масу цієї суміші,
якщо сумарна кількість речовин
суміші становить 0,5 моль.
Що таке «еквімолярна»?
«Екві-» означає «рівні».
Для того, щоб ви краще собі
це уявили, наприклад:
5 мандаринів і 5 яблук. Це - різні
фрукти, але їх кількість рівна,
тобто еквімолярна.
Отже, еквімолярна - рівна кількість.
Переходимо до розв’язання задачі.
Для того, щоб розв’язати задачу,
потрібно її зрозуміти.
На мою думку, якщо ви зрозуміли задачу,
ви можете записати скорочений
запис і тоді задачу ви,
найбільш ймовірно, розв’яжете.
Отже, читаємо ще раз умову.
Ми щойно з вами сказали, що еквімолярна
суміш - це рівна кількість.
Кількість позначаємо літерою «n»,
Купрум(II) оксид - CuO дорівнює
кількості Ферум(II) оксиду.
Виходить таке рівняння:
N (Cu2O) = n (FeO)
Читаємо далі задачу: обчисліть масу
цієї суміші, якщо n суміші = 0,5 моль.
Нам визначити треба
масу суміші (у грамах).
Mаса - знак питання.
Для того, щоб розв’язати задачу, нам
потрібно розуміти, як знайти масу.
Суміш складається з двох різних речовин.
Для того, щоб знати масу суміші, нам
треба знати і масу Купрум(II) оксиду,
і масу Ферум(II) оксиду.
Пригадаймо, як знайти масу.
Для того, щоб знайти масу,
треба кількість речовини
помножити на молярну масу.
Молярну масу дізнатися буде нескладно,
оскільки ми маємо формули.
Як знайти кількість?
За умовою задачі, у нас
кількість всієї суміші.
Для того, щоб далі розв’язати
задачу, ми маємо розуміти,
що в еквімолярній сумі кількість
кожної речовини однакова.
От у нас є кількість речовини,
яка становить 0,5 моль.
Складається ця суміш із СuO і FeО.
Якщо їх рівна кількість, то це
0,25 моль Купрум(II) оксиду
і 0,25 моль - Ферум(II) оксиду.
Тепер ми знаємо кількість
кожної речовини.
Знаючи кількість кожної речовини,
ми можемо знайти масу.
Давайте почнемо з CuO.
Маса CuO - це добуток кількості
Купрум(II) оксиду на молярну масу.
Кількість - 0,25 моль.
Для того, щоб знайти молярну масу CuO,
треба подивитися в періодичну
систему хімічних елементів:
яка відносна атомна маса
кожного елементу.
Купрум в таблиці - 64, Оксиген - 16.
Отже, маса - 80 г/моль.
Моль і моль скорочуються.
Давайте порахуємо усно: 0,25 - це 1/4.
Тобто для того, щоб помножити
0,25 на 80, 80 можна поділити на 4.
Отже, вага CuO  буде 20 грамів.
Тепер знайдемо масу Ферум(II) оксиду.
Аналогічно: множимо кількість
на молярну масу.
Кількість - 0,25 моль.
Молярна маса Феруму
в таблиці - 56, оксигену - 16.
Рахуємо усно чи у стовпчик. 56 + 16.
Отже, маса Ферум(II) оксиду - 72 г/моль.
Знову одиниця вимірювання -
моль - скорочується.
Далі потрібно 72 помножити на 0,25.
Це все одно що поділити 72 на 4.
Або 72 двічі поділити на 2.
Отримаємо 18. Така маса FeO.
Тепер ми можемо знайти
загальну масу суміші.
Це сума маси Купруму та Феруму:
20 г + 18 г = 38 г.
Отже, якщо взяти еквімолярну суміш
Купрум(II) оксиду і Ферум(II) оксиду
загальною кількістю 0,5 моль, то маса
цієї суміші становитиме 38 грамів.
Продовжуємо. Наступне завдання.
Складіть рівняння хімічних реакцій,
які відповідають схемам
послідовних перетворень.
От сьогодні на році ми з вами
вже підходимо до того,
який зв'язок існує між класами
неорганічних сполук.
Пропоную розв’язати
таку схему перетворень.
Натрій перетворюється на натрій гідроксид,
Натрій гідроксид на Натрій карбонат,
Натрій карбонат на Натрій хлорид
і Натрій хлорид на Натрій сульфат.
Ми маємо написати 4 рівняння
хімічної реакції.
1. Натрій перетворюється
на Натрій гідроксид.
Що тут треба пригадати: ми з вами
на минулому уроці говорили,
що таке лужні елементи
і чому вони так називаються.
Я нагадаю, лужні вони тому,
що з водою утворюють луг.
Тобто для того, щоб добути Натрій
гідроксид із Натрію, треба додати воду.
Як відбувається реакція:
якщо воду уявити як НОН,
то Натрій стає замість Гідрогену.
Відбувається реакція заміщення:
натрій заміщує Гідроген у воді.
Утворюється Натрій Гідроксид
і виділяється Водень.
Це я записала схему хімічної реакції.
Вона містить вихідні речовини і продукти.
Тепер давайте розставимо
коефіцієнти і перетворимо
цю схему на рівняння хімічної реакції.
Натрій до реакції - 1 і після так само.
Оксиген - 1 і 1 відповідно.
Гідроген до реакції - 2, а після - 3.
Там, де непарне число атомів
Гідрогену, ставимо число 2.
Тепер Натрію стало 2.
Тому до реакції ставимо теж 2.
Гідроген - 4 до реакції.
Тому перед водою ставимо коефіцієнт 2.
Перевіряємо за Оксигеном: Оксиген
до реакції - 2 і після реакції - 2.
Наступна реакція.
Із Натрій гідроксиду треба
добути Натрій карбонат.
Ми вже з вами говорили
на попередньому уроці
про хімічні властивості
розчинних у воді основ.
Розчинні у воді основи -
луги, реагують і з кислотами,
і з кислотними оксидами
з утворенням солей.
Проте у цьому випадку краще
взяти не кислоту, а оксид кислотний.
Тому що карбонатна кислота
існує лише в розчині.
Краще взяти СО2, він пропускають
крізь розчин Натрій гідроксиду.
Тоді відбувається хімічна реакція.
Для того, щоб зрозуміти,
як вона відбувається,
ми маємо пригадати,
яка кислота відповідає
вуглекислому газу - Карбон(IV) оксиду,
це карбонатна кислота (Н2СО3).
І СО2 в хімічній реакції поводиться
так само, як і карбонатна кислота.
Тобто відбувається, по суті,
реакція обміну.
Натрій стає на місце Гідрогену -
вийде Натрій (II) Карбонат.
Гідроген заміщає Натрій - вийде вода.
Цю схему перетворюємо
на рівняння хімічної реакції.
Натрій до реакції - 1,
після реакції стало 2,
тому перед Натрієм гідроксиду
ставимо коефіцієнт 2.
Карбон до і після реакції - 1,
тому так і залишаємо.
Гідроген до і після реакції - 2.
Оксиген - до реакції:
2+2=4, після - 3+1=4.
Наступна реакція.
Із Натрій карбонату треба
отримати Натрій хлорид.
Натрій карбонат - сіль слабкої кислоти.
Натрій хлорид - сіль сильної кислоти.
Сильна кислота може витискати слабку.
У цьому випадку буде відбуватися реакція
між натрієм карбонату
і хлоридною кислотою.
Реакція обміну: Натрій стає на місце
Гідрогену, буде Натрій хлор.
Н замість Na утворить Н2СО3,
нестійку кислоту,
яка під час утворення розкладається
на вуглекислий газ і воду.
Перетворюємо схему на рівняння.
Натрій до реакції - 2, а після - 1.
Тому ставимо перед Натрій хлором
коефіцієнт 2.
Хлор тепер стало 2, перед НСL ставимо 2.
Гідрогену до і після реакції - 2.
Карбон - 1 і 1.
Оксиген до і після реакції - 3,
тому так і залишається.
Четверте рівняння реакції - із Натрій
хлориду треба добути Натрій сульфат.
Хочу зупинитися на цій реакції.
І Натрій хлорид - це сіль,
утворена сильною кислотою,
і Натрій сульфат - це сіль,
утворена сильною кислотою.
Проте у цьому випадку реакція
буде відбуватися,
оскільки сульфатна кислота
все-таки сильніша.
І за яких умов відбувається така реакція:
якщо Натрій хлорид - тверда речовина,
а сульфатна кислота - концентрована.
Саме за таких умов може
відбуватися хімічна реакція.
Таким чином, в лабораторних умовах
можна добути Гідроген хлорид.
Знову перетворюємо схему
на рівняння хімічної реакції.
Натрій після реакції - 2,
а до реакції - 1.
Тому ставимо коефіцієнт 2
перед натрій хлоридом.
Хлор до реакції  - 2, а після - 1,
тому теж ставимо 2 перед НСL.
Сульфур до і після реакції - 1,
Гідроген - 2, Оксиген - 4.
Отже, ми зараз з вами
виконали таке завдання:
ми написали рівняння хімічних
реакцій, які відповідають схемам.
Додому вам буде аналогічне завдання.
Останні дві схеми вам
потрібно дописати вдома:
схема перетворення з Кальцієм
(металічним елементом) і з Купрумом.
Це буде домашнє завдання.
На цьому ми закінчуємо.
Я вам дуже вдячна за увагу.
До зустрічі! На все добре!